colts have won three of their last four
after starting the season 0-3 while the
niners have gone the opposite direction
they have now lost four straight games
so teams trending in opposite directions
as we take you back to a very rainy
santa clara where we welcome in jack
collinsworth and rodney harrison to the
conversation rodney you know michelle
had an umbrella she had her notes in her
hand no problem she had
lots of things that she was holding i
don't know that you can do that
catherine let me tell you something if
you guys aren't smart enough to
negotiate a professional umbrella holder
in your contracts don't get mad at me
are you guys under cover i messed that
up you're under chris i messed that up
as well that's why i ended up having to
hold rodney's umbrella
because i messed
this is one of those true slot fest
backyard football type games so who won
the head coaching battle who called a
better game in the school i thought
frank wright did an excellent job i
thought he did a great job of running
the football with his running back
jonathan taylor but also taking shots
and being aggressive down the field and
as a defensive back that's one of the
toughest things to do is to try to make
a play on the football when the ball is
being thrown down there and it's the
weather and all these different problems
and i thought frank wright did the right
thing testing that secondary and that
secondary looked really really bad
carson wins he's trying to put together
this second chapter of his career trying
to do it in indianapolis what's your
take on his game dude this i call this
the new carson wins because he looks so
confident he looks so composed and he
looks so patient and i love seeing his
carson wentz and his teammates they
never fluttered they always believed in
him and all the way down to the end and
you see that beautiful pass that he
threw to michael pittman jr that was
that was just a thing of beauty we got
to hit this 49er side of the ball though
coach shanahan jimmy garoppolo what's
wrong right now with this passing game
for the niners well it's it's kyle
shanahan yeah because his biggest
problem is he doesn't trust jimmy g
enough to throw the ball down the field
and defenses are sitting on the routes
they're playing overly aggressive they
don't have to worry about the ball going
over their head so they're just sitting
on routes and they're right in the guy's
face and then i think the second thing
too is if you think about it they don't
have anybody outside of debo samuel who
else do they have you're looking for
ross dwelling to step up kyle's
youscheck they just don't have that
second deep threat down the field how do
they get iu going how did they get him
going what would be your strategy to get
his game to come back to life look i
love john lynch and but that's the wrong
thing to do you draft a guy that high
you don't criticize them in the media
okay you don't criticize them if
anything what you do you bring them in
and you say look we're going to get you
the ball we believe in you we're going
to get you the ball quick and early and
that builds his confidence
chris sims how about for you what'd you
see from shanahan this 49ers offense
well i'll hit on some of the same points
that rodney just made i think he's spot
on to a degree you know you see with the
49ers offense hey the run game it's
creative when they get you with all
their misdirection stuff they seem
really tough to stop on the offensive
side of the ball here's the first drive
of the game or at least some successful
plays from the early part of the game
look at all the misdirection that goes
on not only pre-snap but post-snap you
don't know where guys are going and of
course it created huge holes in the run
game so that is when you see shanahan at
his best this they fell into a trap of
this beating this in the second quarter
and really some dull moments where the
offense didn't produce anything it was
just straight ahead running the football
second half hey jack your your dad
mentioned it this looked like the first
drive of the game i mean chris collins
earth was all over it it got back to
misdirection it played into the wow it's
a colts it's a fast defense but we don't
they're over pursuing with all the
shanahan misdirection but i think the
point that rodney and i want to get back
to it rodney because you know one you
said it there's only one receiver to
think about and when you play the 49ers
right now it's run game and the pass
game is right over the middle in between
the hashes and they don't make you
defend enough of the field in my opinion
and that goes kind of back to your point
with only debuff samuel being the only
wide receiver threat for that offense
hey chris when you're watching the tape
do you see what i see like he's so
afraid to push the ball down the field
and i don't know if that has anything to
do with you know um jimmy g and the
super bowl or what's going on but he has
to push the ball down the field and i
asked darius leonard this week did he
see the same thing he said yeah we saw
we see the same thing they're not
throwing the ball down the field so what
do you say to something like that no i i
think you know they could take a a page
out of like what the colts did tonight i
mean you know rodney a lot of db's in
football can't play the ball when it's
50 yards down the field right we saw all
the pass interference calls the colts
created by taking shots down the field
but i think your point's real there just
has to be a little bit of a willingness
a little bit to go wait debo samuel is
better than this guy we like his match
up versus this corner who's less than
him let's throw a 20-yard out round
let's throw a 15-yard comeback let's
find some ways to push the ball down the
field to what rodney you're saying and
hey rodney i want to ask you a question
like talk about
how hard it is to defend the the
shanahan offense that we saw in the
first drive of the game with all the
misdirection runs and then that first
drive of the second quarter with all the
bootlegs going everywhere is it safety
as a defender what does that do to you
they they seem to have lost their way a
little bit in that uh throughout the
game yeah i was telling jack too i said
the problem with kyle shanahan's offense
is it tests your discipline as a team so
you you can't be looking around trying
to figure out something you have to
stick to your technique you have to make
sure that you do your job and that's the
most important thing and that's what we
were talking about we're like well
they're having success with all the
misdirection the bootlegs and things
like that why don't they come back to it
but of course coaches outsmart
themselves and they feel like hey i
can't do what's been giving me success
they're going to catch up i got to do
something totally different and that's
something that chris that i just totally
don't believe in jeff you were saying
that frank reich he just continues to
push the ball down the field not even
necessarily to go let's go catch a deep
play but let's create an opportunity
where db has to decide basically whether
he's going to make contact with
receivers they're not getting their head
around to find the ball what's wrong
with that brother let me just tell you
this when i'm when i'm watching tape on
indianapolis and carson wentz is
dropping back this is the most relaxed
i've seen him he's dropping back even on
film the last couple games he's throwing
the ball down the field no problem
because his coach believes that he can
do that and that's something that's
really holding this offense back chris
sims is kyle shanahan your boy he will
not trust jimmy g enough to throw the
ball down the field and if he can't
trust him to throw the ball down the
field they need to sever ties with him
and they need to move forward and stick
with trey for next year well rodney and
jack i mean you make a lot of good
points i think that's what they're
trying to do that's why they probably
drafted trey lance a little bit of that
element yeah jimmy garoppolo is not
great at throwing the ball down the
field he doesn't have a real strong arm
to be thrown 15 and 20 yard out routes
so i think there is a little bit of a
fear of that but that doesn't mean he
can't do it and i think to the point
jack and and both you you guys both made
there you know one to take the shots
down the field jack like you were
mentioning hey at the very least it
makes the defense think wait we got to
look behind us a little bit we can't
always just come downhill come downhill
the colts defense got to come downhill
all night long the 49ers had to think
about like whoa wait are they going to
take a shot are they going to throw a
ball play action pass or just a
one-on-one shot and that's an element
that's certainly missing from the 49ers
offense all good offenses and football
make you defend the whole field and for
right now the colts are making to defend
the whole field the 49ers are only
making you defend the middle of the
field and that's why they've lost four
games in a row or at least a big part of
it in my opinion hey chris as a db you
said the most important thing you said
when a ball is thrown down the field
especially in this weather it's hard for
dbs a we see this every single week to
locate the ball they struggle locating
the ball right but they also but they
also struggle and they grab the
receivers they're grabbing the receivers
and you don't there's no need he's in
perfect position you cannot touch the
receiver and this is a veteran
cornerback this um nickelback kaelon
williams he's one of the best in an nfl
but once again look at emmanuel mosley
you cannot grab any time they see your
hand goes away from your body and touch
the receiver once again
who is this uh is that josh norman
grabbing and holding you can't do that
but once again i thought frank wright
had an excellent game plan he saw what i
saw on film with these db's he said
these guys aren't very good they can't
run they can't play the ball so carson
we're gonna throw the ball down the
field about seven eight times and we're
going to give you an opportunity to make
plays rob this has just been an icy cold
stretch for the 49ers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports